so um as i said before the
tone mapper we will look at was
developed by reinhardt at all
in siggraph 2002 presented
so it's all it has it had already some
time to prove
itself so to say it's widely used so
most light simulation products and also
hdr photography tools you have it
and it has both a global and a local
variant
so they were both presented
here you see the difference between a
global and the local approach
um yes in some way i mean
um usually convolution is by a fixed
candle
so your kernel function is the same um
here this could be a non-linear kernel
so it's not that it's linear convolution
in the sense that you have one fixed
kernel
that does it but you have a non-linear
mapping
in this sense it's not really a
convolution
but the implementations can
are in disappeared so if you want to
have it fast
so parallelization parallelization
strategies
that work for convolutions also work for
that
um usually you i will go into the local
approach later but you usually have to
adapt
the feature size so either then you do
multiple passes with different
discretizations of your kernel size
or you take a huge call and vary the
current function so
okay here the difference between a
global and a local approach
i'm not 100 sure how well this is
perceivable on this project or
but for example you see that the local
approach
is much more contrast in the cupula path
or for example in the um
in the mosaics on the church room
but the global one already works very
well
is faster but doesn't give you all the
possibilities
that your eye would give you
so the steps this is just a short
outline i will explain
what this meant with this formulas of
course if you want to have in
in-depth details on this um the
references at the end of the lecture
so um here i present the global version
so you now have one mapping function of
the whole image
of the luminance values of the whole
image
to a color space
so the first thing you do is you compute
some kind of average
of the image so since you do not know if
this is is this inherently a very dark
image or is it um globally a very bright
image you somehow have to set
the baseline so to say
and this is done with the log average
so you don't just average the
um the sun
so you don't sum up and divide because
this would give
um unproportional weight to the
large values because they are somehow
exponentially distribute that you can
imagine
so this takes care of that so you
you average in log space and then
convert back into exponential
and then you have some kind of average
of your scene
so this is the approximate average
brightness
of the image that i'm looking at and
then you map this
to a middle gray value so a
is now what what you define as you want
to have middle gray
this you can vary this also depends on
what the ranges
you have available
and this now sets the bar so everything
above this little gray will be brighter
everything below would be darker
and then um
what you do is you take the middle gray
value
and um scale the input accordingly to it
so now you don't have an input in some
kind of arbitrary range
but you have it relative to the middle
gray value
and then what you do is that you
compress the high luminances
so as you um if you remember from before
this division
division by a maximum which gave you
just a single bright spot in the image
this is because the high luminances
dominate usually dominate the scene but
are only
of very small extent in the scene itself
imagine
looking at the sun i mean the sun is
very small
when compared to the whole sky dome but
it would dominate it as
immensely higher brightness values than
the
surrounding blue of the sky so what you
do here
is now that you uh map your
scaled luminance values to the final
output
by compressing the higher luminances so
in the uh lower right you see the
function the mapping function
so um as you see that
a huge range say
from value 4 to 10
in the x-axis is mapped to a rather
small part in the y-axis
that means that a lot of large
luminances are just compressed in a
small
range in the say rgb values
and what you also have is that
the small luminance so the here the
small luminances in the input
file or in the input image are mapped to
a larger
extent on the y-axis this you can see
that the slope of the function starts
out as nearly
vertically
go at the 45 degree you have a 1 1
mapping
which is approximately a 2 and then you
have a compression
so what this mapping does it it
compresses the high luminances
and enhances the low luminances
and this then gives you the mapping and
you can convert this into
so i go back so the output luminances
then
have are in a predefined range from zero
to one
and can then be mapped to whatever color
space you like
so the local version this is now the one
that takes the neighbors into account
starts off similarly so you compute the
log
average to get an estimate how is the
average brightness of my scene
then you map the values to average gray
that means that the value of 1 is now
my the middle grade
that i defined but now
i do not compress the luminance by one
uniform function over the whole image
but a locally adapted dysfunction by
looking at the neighbors
so now
this the local average
uppercase v now depends
um not only on the coordinates in the
image
so x and y so the pixel that i'm there
right now
but it also depends on some kind of
scale
the scale means um how uniform
are my brightness distributions there so
are am i at a say a silhouette
where half of it is very dark half of it
is very bright
or am i in a homogeneous region
because in homogeneous regions your eye
would
adapt on a larger extent
on the retina to this brightness and
if it's accommodated to this brightness
it can differentiate
details better you perhaps have already
experienced it when you look at the moon
so if you look quickly at the moon it's
just a bright spot
but the longer you look at it the more
details you can discern in it
this is an adaptation of your eye to it
and this happens also
at local spots on the retina and this is
what's
simulated here so you compute for every
pixel position x
y and local scale
and with this local scale you then
you compute the local average v and this
now gives you
how much range compression is going to
happen
at this location
so um so how to get this cave
so the scale is the
extent of an area around
this pixel where the brightness does not
change too much
so in this example where you have a
colorful church window this is that is
illuminated from outside
you have three different examples
on how how you can
put the influencer region of your scheme
so the reinhardt tone mapper does this
by
computing two uh ready
and then look at a certain um
um scale them in a way that they have a
certain behavior
so in the very top you see
you assume that the pixel is in the
center of the two concentric circles
so this is the pixel that i want to
torment now
and if i lie
if i um put two concentric small circles
around it
then i see that um that the center area
the smaller circle is quite smooth in
the distribution of brightnesses
but the outer circle is very smooth too
so there is no
significant difference between the small
and the large circle
that means that my scale is too small
that means that
i could enlarge my circles even more and
still
retain smoothness in the center example
you see the correct application so the
the center disc has smooth values
so there are approximately the same
brightness
but if you take now the outer circle
that intersects the window
you see that suddenly in this footprint
very large brightness values are so you
see that the small
circle is smooth but the surrounding
area is not smooth
and this is what you want to achieve
when you determine the local scale
so the larger the local scale is
the the more um
you are looking at the large patch of
equal
brightnesses and your eye would adapt to
that
that means that for this pixel you can
improve the contrast
because your eye will do the same
another failure case what you should not
do is
that you make the discs too large as the
as shown in the bottom example
because here bright values are already
in the inner disk
so this scale would be too large
i go back so what you get but is
when you know the scale you know um
in
how large the region is where you can
compute your local
average and this then allows you to
locally compress your range so
if it's very smooth you compress less if
you're
next to very bright boundaries you're
so if you are very if you're next to um
discontinuities in the brightness in
your image so there
you are at the verge of traversing from
a bride to a
team region or vice versa you do the
opposite
yeah the ratio between the larger radius
or smaller is constant exactly
yeah this is their approach that they
take there
and then you have to find this i mean
they
uh also um show you an implementation
how this can be
efficiently mapped because i mean trying
all the possible
circles is or disks is not feasible
so you need some kind of approximation
that gives you
a good estimate of that because also if
you go to the corner of the image then
some part of this circle is missing
um yeah i mean then i mean i don't know
how they handled this but i would guess
that they just ignore everything that's
out of the image so you have to cope
with what you have there
and but this is natural in the corners
of your image
you get less neighborhood so you get
less information of how the surrounding
looks like
so you will get say less optimal tone
mapping there
so um here another difference
i zoom in in the image before
so as you can see the
angel figures on the wall are have a
much higher contrast
and this is now because the brightness
values there
are relatively constant so if you
compare this
with say the window next to it
then this has a very uniform
brightness even if the colors are
perhaps different
this is still a low range as you saw
before
between sun and moon it was 800 000
between black and white it was 100 or
so um the if you have direct or indirect
illumination
counts much more than just color
variations of your surface
so here the network corrects directly in
its local version
that the brightness values are quite
uniform
in this region so it enhances the
contrast
so um now this was this uh
concludes the reinhardt told me but
there are also other um
tone mapping approaches so in this
um seek graph 2002 was the year of the
tone mappers
because there were three tone mapping
approaches presented
so one of those was the bilateral filter
perhaps you already heard of bilateral
filtering
in computer vision perhaps
there this is you can imagine it as a
torsion smoothing
that does not smooth over edges so
if you have a large difference in your
image
then it does not smooth this away
so this is you can also call it edge
preserving smoothing
and you can imagine that this is somehow
conceptually similar to this scale
estimation of a reinhardt because the
scalar estimation looks
where do the brightness values
differ a lot so these are say my
brightness edges
in the image and then it doesn't try to
propagate contrast enhancement over this
edge and
the bilateral filters can do the same
thing because they just stop the
filtering process it edges
then another approach by fatal
gradient processing this
is
you can imagine an image say
you have only a luminous
channel of a single color then you can
imagine your
image as a height function so bright
spots um
correspond to high peaks dim regions to
low values
and what they do in this work
is that they look at the gradients
so how steep are the slopes in my image
and then the compress in gradient range
this allows them to
to preserve low gradients
because these are small slopes are the
uh are the details in the dimly
illuminated regions
and the and the very high slopes
are the ramp ups to the bright spots
so if you just say
reduce the high gradients
you also get a similar behavior that you
only
reduce the range in non-uniform regions
so these are three approaches that do
approximately the same they
have the same underlying idea but
they have different approaches to it so
the one of reinhardt
goes more into what's used in um
in photography with there are these
exposure plates that you can use
bilateral filtering immediately uses a
well
established filtering paradigm
in signal processing but
it's most likely very suboptimal from a
perceptual point of view
um gradient processing allows a very
fast application
but perceptionally of these through
works
that i end up tone map is the best and
this speed increases that you perhaps
needed
um 13 years ago are not really relevant
now so
you don't need to take approximations
that were highly relevant before into
account anymore
and just do the and just yeah
have something that's less efficient but
gives you a out of the box nice solution
and um if you check wikipedia
um the german version has a longer list
they list approximately 20 different
variants
the literature for that is reinhardt not
only started that
but also continued researching that and
he's
seen as one of the say experts
that to go to when tone mapping is
concerned
he wrote a book about that so high
dynamic range imaging
and you can also see these three papers
if you
want to know how this field developed
you just
check for example the reinhardt paper on
the digital library of acm
you can do this from here from the
university so you get an account
you get immediate access to the whole
digital library of acm
and there you can just click on cited by
and then you get the long list of papers
that referenced the original work by
reinhardt
and then you can sort them by years and
look what different approaches were used
good that concludes the tone mapping
part are there any questions
okay if not or if you know
which method is being used can we also
do
vice versa um
to some extent
um because
i mean you're inherently losing
information
because
okay the sata thing where you for sure
lose
um precision is if you have before
say 24-bit values and then you encode
them in
8-bit rgb values then you have a
quantization
of your brightness values this is
unrecoverable
this is just lost the other thing is if
you use local approaches
that take um
that take the neighborhood information
into account and then
do um different things in different
regions of the image then it could be
that you have some kind of ambiguity
if you want to reverse this process
because then
it could be that you either had say
in the original data large brightness
values and this at a small scale
or and a large range compression then or
the range was already small like that
and you just use less compression
so you you do
not have the full information how local
approaches
adapt to certain parts of the image
you will have to infer this somehow
i would guess like an optimization
approach so you would like that
locally you should have the same scale
that you assume that you reconstruct and
then you can
recover your signal but you will not be
able to recover all of it
um with global approaches it should be
possible
yeah okay
yeah if you combine the global and the
local ones as the rhino2
does are they weighted in any way or
if you look here the local version
has this expression so the
the scaled luminance is then divided by
some kind of local average
and the global version the first two
steps are identical
but then it uses the scaled value only
at the very center
to say compute this local
average so the global version is a
special case of the local version
that there is not a certain waiting
government
if you uh yeah and you combine the
global picture
local
the luminance output this is what you
get so for each um
picture location you get a scaled
luminance between zero and one
by the global approach and by the local
approach so here
it also immediately gives you the output
luminance so that there is no
combination going on
further questions okay
then thank you for your attention and
this concludes
this rendering lecture
you